Okay, we are
live.
Hi. I am quite tired, but I figured I
would come back and do just a short
evening stream
tonight. Probably just work on a couple
of experiments, see if I can clean up a
few small
things, and then yeah, we'll call it a
night early. That is the plan.
Just do a couple quick things on this.
And then the main thing I want to fix is
the grid
environment. Main thing is the grid
environment.
That doesn't work at all. So, we'll just
leave it as as it was like this
Okay, so this is how
I
8192 problem is I'm pretty sure that
this thing just like crashes,
1024. Wait, you shouldn't need at least
1024 ends,
right? You know, this works.
Okay, so this does
run and this gives you max
size and then do we just plateau at 2?
Is that what happens?
600k. It's kind of slow as well. Oh, I
guess it's because the low batch
size and but this is not learning
anywhere near as quickly as
this. I guess I could do like this kind
of a
thing and I could
see if this is better or not.
So the tricky thing here, right,
is I don't know if I broke training or
the
end. The easiest thing to
do would be to go get the old end files,
I
guess. Unless this just runs, but I
doubt
it. Yeah, I think the easiest thing to
do is going to be to go get the old end
files, test versus
those and uh then see from
there because this definitely doesn't
I don't know why that happens where I
just randomly delete stuff.
Weird hot cake.
Max
size. Max map
it? But this is also not the version I
was
using. Do I just go to the first version
before I did all this stuff?
Damn
it.
I thought I did this
more. I didn't do this five months ago,
right? Yeah. No, I didn't do this five
months ago.
Okay. So, this doesn't train
either, it seems to me.
And I
have yeah all the same
Now I mean stuff is different since I
did this.
If I just delete the param that I don't
think makes
sense. I should probably let this run a
little longer to be sure
though. Pretty damn sure though that I
had it working way quicker than this. It
was working.
What do I think the odds are? It's the
horizon.
right?
No. Oh, cuz you're editing the wrong
file, [ __ ]
Are you on a desktop or is this a
laptop? This is definitely a
desktop. I have two very nice desktops
next to me and another eight out in the
garage. Okay, that at least does
something.
So, we'll let this train and we'll
see. That'd be funny if it were
literally just the horizon that I messed
up. I would have better lighting here as
well, but I'm kind of sick of staring at
this ring light at night. This freaking
white themed dashboard is bad enough as
is.
Okay. So, this is this is where it
was. So, now I try this
on the new version of the env. I see if
they
match. I'm going to let this run a
little though. At least run a little
And then if this works, I'll be pretty
confident that the new experience buffer
is
good. Yeah, cuz
um we have a little write up on the
hardware for this as
well. Right
here, hover stack.
Okay. 76
79. This gets like 80%ish and 63
mil. It's pretty
good. So then for grid, I just remove
this and then I try this on grid and I
see if this works.
Okay. Well, this will be a relief if
this is all I had to
fix. And then I get to just I guess it's
8:24, so I'll just spend like half an
hour ablading out what actually matters
with this grid environment.
We'll have a decent
baseline and then uh I'll be able to do
the new curriculum learning stuff on
this just
fine. I mean, it makes sense. It really
should work.
made so many
improvements in the last two weeks.
enough. It does eventually get better,
right?
mattered. Oh, that's unbearably slow.
We're not doing that
one. We'll change more things than I
probably
should. It's my better judgment.
well. So, we'll keep this one. What if
we just keep
this bigger
batch? Try this next.
is Okay, these are all the same
speed, so this didn't
help. It doesn't seem like it hurt too
badly, but uh it's not great.
do if we're going to 4x the batch size
like that, we should
4x the
ends and see if that helps because that
at least that goes faster maybe.
Yeah, there you go. That's at least
faster
now. So, if we do this in wall clock, we
might actually win.
Why is offline RL all the rage
nowadays? Because people gave up on
online because they couldn't figure it
out. We're still doing
online. Offline only works if you have a
data
set. It's also a misnomer. A better name
for offline RL would be supervised
learning. It's not really RL.
The entire point and the entire
difficulty of RL is that you are
learning interactively from an
everchanging environment. Offline is not
welcome. So, yeah, we're not really
doing offline at the moment because
there's no point. It's just easy. And um
that's not to say we won't mix in data
if we have it. It's just the thing is we
don't really need to study it because
it's just easy. It's just imitation
learning. Okay. So, this works. What I'm
doing here, by the way. So, this is the
maze environment. I can show it real
quick. Why don't I just show it? So,
this is our uh our maze environment.
Looks like this. Just you make different
size mazes. You have to solve the maze.
Uh you only get a reward for solving the
entire maze. So, it's very very sparse.
It's pretty much a pure exploration
task. And we use this for research on,
as you'd imagine, exploration, but also
curriculum learning because you can like
make maps that are smaller and maps that
are larger. And you can like learn the
smaller maps first and stuff like that.
Um, so I'm currently trying to make sure
that this is in good shape because we
have active research that depends on
this end. And uh, this one's actually a
little tricky
infrastructure-wise, but yeah, there you
go.
Oh, I bet I know why it got slower as
well. Yeah, I know how to fix that.
Try
this. See if that works. Active research
with mazees involve scaling laws. Uh,
no, that's something quite separate. Um
that is something that we probably
should be doing at some point. But
um the scaling laws thing is more like
predict results of from small experiment
on n of large experiment on n. We kind
of just try to solve a lot of different
ms with the same methods for the most
part.
There's definitely a place for scaling
law research. We don't do a ton of stuff
with that right
now. We do get predictably better
results though uh with larger models on
at least one of the m the bigger M's
neural MMO
3. Okay, if this just stopped working
that will be very interesting to
know. I wonder which parameter it was
that mattered.
huh? Okay, let's try these
um one at a time.
I mean, pretty much not all of our
research, but most of our research
happens right here on stream. Obviously,
we have other collaborators doing other
stuff, and not everybody streams
everything, but I pretty much stream all
of my
work. Tomorrow is probably going to be a
deep dive into modelbased
RL potentially.
At least I'm going to start doing that
in the morning and we're going to see
how it
goes. I don't really want to like rip
out PO and put in a whole another
algorithm. I kind of just want like a
model based AUGs objective that I can
use. Hey bet. What do you mean finally
streaming? I've been streaming like
various chunks of the whole day. Model
based RL's hard.
No, people are just bad at
it. It's not really
like if anything it should be
easier because you burn stupid amounts
of compute on uh relatively simple
problems. I mean we have this
paper ski it is literally skill issue
here. Let me show you this.
So, Dreamer V3 made it into
uh Dreamer V3 recently made it to
nature. Well, here's our ner paper
showing that half of it's
wrong. All the like the paper itself
works, but all the tricks they said are
the reason it works, the tricks all
suck. So,
Yeah, it's it's literally just people
are
bad. It's mostly just nobody taking the
time to do engineering correctly really.
It's like a bunch of scientists without
proper engineering support who don't
really know how to code properly
themselves. Interesting that this
actually made a difference
here. It's a big difference.
Oh, hang on. There's a time
Uh we believe that dreamer does work
just not for the reasons
stated. Like the thing is that they kind
of gloss over the fact that dreamer v3
is a 10 times larger model than dreamer
v2.
So they like they train a 10x larger
model and then they like say, "Oh, look,
we came up with all these clever tricks
when it seems like really the most
important thing is the fact that they
trained a 10x larger
model." And then maybe like a few small
things like layer actually helped them
train the bigger model. I don't know. It
was very very weird, I will say.
Okay. So, it's interesting that the
hyperparameters here actually do seem to
make a
difference. The higher entropy actually
hurts. Like
really hurts a little
bit. We have this
one. The [ __ ] did they not do ablations?
Well, the thing is they did ablations,
right? But they did like add one drop
one. The thing is they like used
reinforce instead of using like a
reasonable algorithm. And then because
they didn't use a reasonable algorithm,
they like had to come up with all these
hacky tricks that just kind of do what
PO does but worse.
So, and the thing is like you know if
this is a well-known uh deep mind
researcher doing this, right? Like you
know that the average random PhD student
doing RL is putting out way worse crap.
Like yeah, RL is not impossible. It's
just like people were really really bad.
Nobody bothered to put in the
engineering. RL takes way more
engineering to do well than any other
area of ML other than like large scale
like the people who actually scale
training of LLMs like those engineers
not the researchers who don't touch
that. Um yeah and like nobody did the
engineering.
So all we're doing all we are doing that
makes us able to do this we're just
doing the
engineering and that's all we're
These prams actually seem to matter
which is
surprising. How about learning rate?
Learning rate was like tuned with Adam,
right? Surely this is better.
I mean, to their credit, right, I'm
probably going to be looking at Dreamer
V3 as a reference tomorrow, but not for
those components, not for any of those
tricks, just for the the core world
model setup and whether it's like
actually compatible and useful with what
we
want. Okay, so this is interesting. The
hypers actually seem to matter here.
Oh, you know what? I wonder if the
hypers matter here because update epox
is set way too
high. If update epox is set like to
four, then this is off policy,
right? Hang
on. What if we just do this one? What
happens?
the ablations that I'm kind of just like
sleepily hacking out right now. Uh each
of these runs would be like 2 hours plus
if we were using
conventional environments and
infrastructure. So like there's just a
very large difference in the speed with
which we can do
things. Okay, that's a respectable
speed. See, now we're at 1.5 million
steps per
second. We change value to relative
time. That's
nice. So then we'll redo the parameter
ablations.
with this because now we're no longer so
off policy provided that this actually
does
decently. This seems
good. Yeah, this is decent so far.
bit, but also like the learning rate
kind
dropped. What happens if we do this?
This is better or worse now. Check both
of these
It actually is worse, isn't
it? Crazy. That makes a difference.
this
point? What do you mean
bad? Oh, did you see? You should check
my latest commit because I changed the
logs and
everything. It's just an unused
variable that shouldn't break compile.
Just a
does. I'll look at it at some point, but
it's Do I need to like if you link it to
me, I'll go tell you what's
wrong. I changed. So all of the M's now
have a PF variable, which is a
normalized single metric that goes from
zero to
one. I did that
today. I left uh I didn't do any new
bindings though, like new I didn't do
new bindings. C. I left that for
you to finish.
It's just single me. It's single metric
that is relevant to the
M. It's 0 to one
normalized. The point is that you can
put all the M's on the same graph.
This does substantially worse as well,
doesn't
it?
Okay, so this does substantially
worse. So except for the So I was going
to call it normalized or except for the
fact that not all the M's have a score
that makes sense.
So in some it's like normal, some of
them it's win rate, some of them it's a
score. It's normalized whichever metric
the N
has. No, because not all the M's have a
completion
condition. So I intentionally named it
something else. So you wouldn't assume
it's just like you know one variable or
another.
something. Yeah, this is actually
something.
I'm just fiddling with this so that
like we have something to go off of for
our curriculum learning work.
something 025. So crazy high learning
rate by comparison. Let's see what this
does.
there. I'm going to send air on one of
these runs and he's going to be like,
"What the h That takes me an hour to
do. Like, yeah, well, it rains in two
minutes
fast? Fastest possible.
Puffer. Puffer.
I'm interested to see here because this
learning rate
O4. Yeah. So, it seems like
um the harder M's need like lower learn
rates. Make sure this doesn't take off
or some
[ __ ] But, you know, we could try a
layer norm.
Is this
better? Oh, yeah, it
is. So, learning rate does actually need
uh tuning. What did I do? It was
honestly solid. I don't know why I'm
manually tuning [ __ ] right now. I'm just
trying to like smash the baseline on
this and give Aaron something
to look at.
potentially. Yeah, it's too
high. We can do 25 like
this. And then that's going to be the
last tune.
Fine. How funny is it going to be if I
like mostly solve this task?
We've been trying to solve this for a
while. Can solve it with hyperparameter
tuning in the new advantage
stuff. 20 minutes more max on this. I'm
going to bed.
worse? You got to be kidding
me. This is actually
worse. You give it like
Still going up pretty
steep. 99
gamma. You're telling me if I put 999
gamma, it's better. Mhm.
Is that how it
works? Yeah. And because I know the math
is why I'm
surprised
because.995 gamma is a very long
horizon.
You do realize though that
like learning over that
is okay. So, it's actually it's pretty
close, right? It actually catches up
pretty
well. But I will go the other way.
We'll see.
9999 999
curve. You don't want it round. Round
means level. You I want a log. You want
log linear always.
Okay,
thankfully there appears to be
sanity, but I'm going to let it run
because it's only a minute and it seems
like
um there is a bit of steepness to it.
linear. Still kind of linear.
[Music]
Did that make it not learn
anything? Something seems very off about
that. Hang on.
Oh, it just doesn't
learn. Okay.
Oh, you know what it is? It's that I'm
really
dumb. It's that I'm really really
stupid and I forgot to
uncomment the thingy and now it probably
everything because I hate Layer Norm and
Larorm hates Okay.
The one good thing about X is that when
it has all this stupid content,
occasionally it has
There's even an entire part
of there's even an entire part of
uh X devoted to seals. Isn't that
lovely?
There are no more seals on the
timeline. I'm
stuck watching the grass, it seems.
This thing had a
crash. Oh no, it's just
Oh. Oh.9. Cool. We're just We're just
solving [ __ ] now, I
guess. Oh, there are more seals I have
found.
good. All right, I guess we just solve
everything tonight, huh?
I think this is good enough to
call 98%.
this no longer exists. We get rid of
this
I should probably just run neural MMO 3
as is on the new version to be honest.
This is our
latest
experiment. It was quite good.
Well, apparently there have been a lot
of changes.
Uh, I don't know how it got
faster. That seems
weird that it would get
faster, but whatever. We will see if it
works.
I don't think it's actually faster. I
think it's a reporting error, but
whatever. Okay, we'll see whether that
does
anything. Did I log a napkin there? No,
I didn't like a dummy.
boxes. I always keep a couple for myself
just so I have them so I can run my own
stuff on my own
boxes. I don't load them 100%, but it's
better that I have them when I need
them.
Cool. We have
uh here we are.
What happened to
I'm still marching
along doing
fine. It's layer
norm. Not
magic, but
um does give you a little bit of perf.
It looks like they still learn a lot
faster at the start as well. So that is
something. Okay, this is
cool. This already does something,
right? That's fine.
So, we'll let these be for
now. Um, seems good to
me. And we have stuff nicely queued up
for
tomorrow. We will run new ablations. We
will run lots of new stuff tomorrow.
9:30. Good time to call it. Get some
sleep. Trying to put in a full
day tomorrow.
Uh, so for the couple folks here, thanks
for tuning
in. More stream tomorrow. Should be some
pretty cool algorithm
dev. All my stuff's at puffer.ai. It's
all open source. If you want to come
support me for free, start the GitHub
almost at
2K. You can join the Discord to get
involved with open source dev. You can
follow me on X for more content.
We are currently
at 1948. Two more before it should round
to
2K. So, thank you. And uh yeah, I'll
merge